[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und wulf schmiese guten abend
heute vor fünf monaten hat russland den
krieg gegen die ukraine begonnen es
gehört nun auch in der eu wo das gas
knapper und das geld immer weniger wert
wird ungarns regierungschef viktor orban
fordert verhandlungen mit russland
vorgestern gab es ja tatsächlich einen
weizen deal doch der wurde gestern mit
raketen besser zumindest angeschossen da
sagten die russen noch wir waren es
nicht heute nun gibt moskau das
gegenteil zu man habe gezielt waffen
zerstören wollen doch russland will noch
mehr zerstören die außenminister lavrov
am nachmittag in kairo kundtat
man werde dem ukrainischen volk auf
jeden fall helfen sich von dem absolut
volks und geschichts feindlichen regime
zu befreien
das ist neu bisher hatte der kreml das
so offen nicht als kriegsziel ausgegeben
was also ist von putins zusagen zu
halten
das habe ich vorhin den früheren
amerikanischen außenminister henry
kissinger gefragt das gespräch gleich in
dieser sendung davor berichtet dara
hassanzadeh was die leute im
angegriffenen odessa von verhandlungen
halten
blauer himmel gelbe felder die farben
der ukraine begleiten uns auf unserem
weg nach süden nach odessa mama die
mutter so nennen die ukraine ihre stadt
am schwarzen meer es ist juli ohne krieg
wäre hochsaison trotz krieg lebt die
stadt amina unterrichtet ihre
tanzschüler im park am tag des getreide
abkommens mit russland
ich denke wir sollten verhandeln weil
menschen sterben und diese menschen
können wir nicht mehr zurückholen
keine 20 stunden später stehen wir hier
filmen mit unserem handy es sind die
explosionen des russischen luftamtes
sie treffen den hafen nur einen guten
kilometer luftlinie entfernt keine toten
aber auch wichtig millionen gelagerte
tonnen getreide fangen kein feuer
zerstört ist das vertrauen der ukraine
in absprachen mit russland und doch
wollen sie ihren teil des getreide
abkommens einhalten
das end minen des meeres wird
fortgesetzt so wie es vertraglich im
abkommen festgehalten wurde das hat das
militärische oberkommando der ukraine
besteht
den schönsten blicke deshalb bietet das
restaurant und locker mit seiner
dachterrasse
sehen und gesehen werden doch seit dem
krieg die dieser satz gefahr es ist ein
arbeitsplatz von dem man sehen kann die
raketen fliegen und einschlagen
natürlich wollen wir dass der krieg
endet wir wollen sicherheit und ruhe ich
wünsche mir dass ich aufhören kann mich
um das leben meiner gäste zu sorgen weil
es ist gefährlich hier oben zu sein
wer hier hochkommt weiß um das risiko
gut essen zu gehen dieser gast spricht
weiterhin nur russisch seine haltung zur
verhandlungen mit russland ist klar
sogar für den fall dass der präsident
oder die regierung entscheiden sollten
besetzten gebiete aufzugeben ich sage
nur falls die ukraine die dafür
gestorben sind sie erlauben es uns nicht
diese gebiete umkehr von mario klotz und
lohans aufzugeben und das heißt mehr als
hafen- und nachtleben europa valette
architektur prägen die stadt wie die
menschen tief verankert auch der
schwarze jüdische humor der odessa juden
ihre raketen sie sind ja im grunde alle
für uns je schneller sie alle zu uns
schicken und so schneller ist alles
vorbei wir sollten auf beograd schießen
und sagen wir waren es nicht und dann oh
wir waren es doch und wir wollten
militär treffen nur leider verfehlt auch
nach fünf monaten krieg sind straßen und
plätze belebt am abend füllen sich die
bars doch seit kriegsbeginn findet das
öffentliche leben ein abruptes ende
ausgangssperre um 23 uhr
früh um diese uhrzeit sind die gäste
erst langsam hier angekommen jetzt
müssen sie gehen
die befürchtungen der behörden sind groß
dass spione ziele ausstehen saboteure
anschläge ausführen könnten
und deshalb bei nacht das ist lehre so
leer wie russische versprechungen sie
hier
in der diplomatie da gibt es kein
scheitern sondern immer nur eine neue
lage dieser satz könnte das lebensmotto
des mannes sein der als ultra
realpolitiker gilt der selbst teils
höchst umstritten ist wegen kriegen und
krisen auf der welt kambodscha vietnam
oder 1 pilot es putsch in chile
damit hatten die usa und eben auch
dieser mann zu tun dominik löschmeister
stellten uns vor
henry kissingers ein weltpolitiker mit
deutschen wurzeln ein befürworter des
dialogs auch im umgang des westens mit
wladimir putin den er immer wieder
getroffen hat von den einen bewundert
als großen staatsmann von den anderen
beschimpft als skrupelloser
machtpolitiker
wird 1923 in fürth geboren hier
verbringt er seine kindheit
1938 gelingt seiner jüdischen familie
die flucht vor den nazis
unter präsident nixon ist kissinger
zunächst sicherheitsberater ab
1973 dann außenminister kissinger der
realpolitiker seine unterschrift
besiegelt das kriegsende in vietnam was
ihm den friedensnobelpreis
einbringt nicht ohne kritik der
kissinger zuvor nächsten darin bestärkt
haben soll die bombardements im
vietnam-krieg auf das neutrale
kambodscha auszuweiten
der freund chinas zwei geheime reisen in
die volksrepublik hat er unternommen
bereitete den weg für nächstens
historischen besuch im reich der mitte
kissingers der machtpolitiker in chile
soll er mit der cia den blutigen putsch
vom kino chat gegen den demokratisch
gewählten präsidenten allende
unterstützt haben
nach dem wort da geht es dann da sinkt
sein stern mit dem seines förderers
nixon er wird politikberater seine
expertise weltweit gefragt in seinem
gerade erschienenen buch staatskunst
verfasst kissingers sein politisches
vermächtnis
hier ist der wohl berühmteste ex
außenminister der welt guten abend henry
kissinger
als 99 jahre alte politiker da haben sie
den kalten krieg nicht nur in gänze
erlebt sondern mit gestaltet ist die
situation heute gefährlicher
die gegenwärtige lage
komplizierter und insofern vielleicht
gefährlicher
dann muss man bedenken dass die
verfügbaren technologien bei als
kontrahenten noch vielschichtiger und
komplizierter sind als dies während des
kalten krieges war
also das führungs vermögen das jetzt
gebraucht wird
das muss auch vielschichtiger und
anspruchsvoller sein
und ja die lage ist kompliziert und
langfristig betrachtet dadurch auch
gefährlicher nun waren sie jemand der
als berater und als außenminister von
präsident nixon ja auch teils mit
blutrünstigen machthabern verhandelt hat
und jetzt ist der westen eigentlich noch
geschlossen der meinung man sollte nicht
mit putin verhandeln sollte der westen
auf putin zu gehen
als außenminister
konnte ich mir die verantwortlichen der
staaten nicht aussuchen mit denen wir
umzugehen hatten was wir getan haben war
darauf angelegt
eine friedvolle und
ordentliche welt zu schaffen
in der gegenwärtigen situation ist es so
dass die verantwortlichen der
demokratien sich darüber klar werden
müssen was sie bereit sind zu fahren und
vorüber und was sie unter gar keinen
umständen bereit sind preis zu geben
und sie werden dies sicher tun müssen in
uneingeschränkter zusammenarbeit mit den
opfern der aggression die
verantwortlichen und das volk in der
ukraine
und wohnen das ist die einzige denkbare
grundlage auf der eine lage nach dem
muster des kalten krieges gehandhabt
werden kann also gibt es im grunde gar
nichts zu verhandeln weil die ukraine
hat klipp und klar gesagt das
territorium soll ganz bleiben also
worüber sollte man dann mit putin
überhaupt verhandeln
was es zu verhandeln gibt
nun
die tatsache dass russland alle gebiete
räumen muss der es nach diesen tag nach
dem kriegsbeginn
erobert hat nun ist aber doch eine
verhandlung mit putin relativ wenig wert
wie wir gerade gesehen haben bei dem
angriff auf odessa nach dem weizen deal
der geschlossen worden ist kam einen tag
später beschuss auf die letzte freie
hafenstadt also was den verhandlungen
bert
verhandlung werden auf jeden fall ruhen
müssen oder der fähigkeit verletzungen
zu verhindern und wenn die
verantwortlichen des westens
das vor den verhandlungen festlegen dann
ist es wichtig sie müssen den griff die
ihnen vorher dessen was sie unter keinen
umständen übersehen werden und
ukrainisches staatsgebiet aufzugeben
sollte nicht eine der bedingungen seien
die wir akzeptieren können sie kennen
putin persönlich sie haben sich mal
getroffen trauen sie ihm zu einen
atomkrieg auszulösen
ob er fähig wäre atomwaffen einzusetzen
das ist ein schwieriges problem vor dem
alle verantwortlichen stehen der einsatz
von kernwaffen würde sicherlich eine
trennlinie überschreiten hinter der es
da ganz schwer sein müssten überhaupt
noch grenzen zu ziehen
und das ist eine bedrohung mit der die
länder sich 80 jahre lang entgegen
getreten sind und seit es seit 80 jahren
kernwaffen epd ist niemand bereit
gewesen diese grenze zu überschreiten
wollte er dies tun dann würde der westin
reagieren müssen uns auf eine art und
weise die ihm klar macht und allen
klarmachen dass kernwaffen nicht
hingenommen werden wie konventionelle
waffen und streitkräfte und natürlich
ein atomkrieg
gleich welcher größenordnung
würde ein maß an zerstörung mit sich zu
mit sich bringen dass verhandlungen so
zu sagen unmöglich machen würde aber am
ende
glaube ich dass der westen putin
abschrecken kann nur er müsste dann eben
auch bereit sein
mit äußerster härte und ernsthaftigkeit
zu reagieren
es gibt so etwas nicht wie einen
begrenzten einsatz hinzunehmen
darauf beruhte ja das gleichgewicht der
kräfte im kalten krieg und darauf beruft
sich auch die ostpolitik von
bundeskanzler willy brandt die sigma
skeptisch sein jetzt hat bundeskanzler
olaf scholz von zeitenwende gesprochen
also ein ende dieser ostpolitik könnte
das sogar der anfang vom ende der
globalisierung seien die sie mit ihrer
china politik begonnen haben und die
nächsten coach einer vor 50 jahren ging
das ja los könnte da jetzt ein endpunkt
erreicht sein
die globalisierte welt durch die durch
die öffnung nach china und durch china
geschaffen wurde steht schwer unter
druck es gibt spannungen zwischen den
usa und china es gab spannungen zwischen
china und anderen staaten in asien
und daher im moment sagen müssen die
annahme
eine
reibungslosen wirtschaften
zusammenarbeit in aller welt das ist nun
sehr gefährdet und ich nehme da dem
deutschen kanzler zu
wir erleben eine zeit auf die der
begriff zeiten wenn wirklich passt und
die herausforderung liegt nun darin
das zu verhindern
was dazu geführt hat dass diese zeit
wendet diese dynamik angenommen hat dass
für dieses gleichgewicht der kräfte nur
noch mühsam herstellen können und eine
gewisse zusammenarbeit
da muss jede anstrengung unternommen
werden um das zu bewahren herr keser
eigentlich hätte ich sie gerne noch nach
ihrem vermächtnis gefragt aber nach dem
gespräch habe ich den eindruck sie sind
auch gar nicht so weit für ein
vermächtnis deswegen worüber werden wir
wohl in fünf jahren mit ihnen sprechen
haben sie etwas optimismus
ich glaube die welt durchläuft einer
zeit des tief greifenden wandels
vergleichbar wenn ich so sagen darf mit
der aufklärung vor jahrhunderten
das heißt
das anerkennen der realität die
fähigkeiten der menschheit
die art und weise wie man
die definition
wissenschaftlicher wahrheit handhabt all
dies durchläuft einen grundsätzlichen
wandel
und natürlich
ist das geht das nie lautlos vor sich
das stört und verstört schafft aber auch
chancen und gelegenheiten der ich glaube
dass am ende dieses prozesses
die fähigkeit stehen wird die
möglichkeit steht mir zu sagen es ist
eine bessere welt zu tage getreten aber
nur wenn die die an diesem prozess
beteiligt sind ihre pflicht tun und
nicht aus den augen verlieren dass sie
der ja noch eine verpflichtung tragen
sie müssen die anwendung der extremsten
und destruktion durch moderne
technologie verhindern
vielen dank henry kissinger für dieses
gespräch und ihnen alles gute und
senke wohingegen herzlich danken folge
dass sie hier mit ihnen reden durfte und
vielen dank auch für die interessanten
fragen
war ein langes gespräch ich weiß wir
haben sogar noch länger gesprochen auch
über trump und die gefahren für die
demokratie in den usa das ganze gespräch
auf zdf heute
und mit dem krieg in europa beginnen
auch die nachrichten mit hanna
zimmermann
bundestags-vizepräsidentin
göring-eckardt hat die kritik polens am
stockenden panzer ringtausch für die
ukraine als weckruf bezeichnet und eine
direkte lieferung ins spiel gebracht es
müsse alles auf den tisch was geht um
die ukraine schnell auszustatten sagte
sie gegenüber dem zdf polen hat bereits
mehr als 200 t-72 kampfpanzer an die
ukraine geliefert
im gegenzug hatte deutschland polen 20
leopard-2-panzer angeboten dies wies die
polnische regierung gestern als
unzureichend zurück
cdu-chef märz hat sich für eine
fortsetzung der sanktionen gegen
russland ausgesprochen sie würden wirken
wenn auch mittel und langfristig sagte
er im zdf-sommerinterview
zudem sprach sich merz für eine
laufzeitverlängerung der atomkraftwerke
in deutschland aus ich sage ihnen auch
voraus sie werden am ende des jahres
sehen dass die laufzeit der
kernkraftwerke verlängert wird gab es
vorgeschlagen die bundesregierung lehnt
ab wenn die bundesregierung mit uns
reden will ernsthaft reden was sie
zurzeit nicht tut wir bieten das immer
an aber wir laufen der bundesregierung
nicht hinterher
papst franziskus ist zu einem
mehrtägigen besuch in kanada
eingetroffen
dort will er vertreter der indigenen
bevölkerung treffen und diese um
vergebung bitten für die jahrzehntelange
gewalt die indigenen kindern in
katholischen internaten angetan wurde
bis in die 90er jahre hinein waren in
kanada etwa
150.000 kinder von ureinwohnern in
kirchlichen heimen untergebracht worden
wieder von ihnen wurden dort misshandelt
oder sexuell missbraucht
mehr als 1000 flüchtlinge wurden an
diesem wochenende aus dem mittelmeer
gerettet der großteil durch die
italienische küstenwache die auf einem
überfüllten fischerboot auch fünf
leichen bergen musste die
hilfsorganisation stil watch konnte bei
mehreren einsätzen nach eigenen angaben
mehr als 440 menschen retten unter ihnen
auch eine hochschwangere frau und ein
kind mit verbrennungen
es wird jetzt ernst gemacht in
deutschland im hochtechnologie land
baden württemberg hat der grüne
ministerpräsident winfried kretschmann
für morgen zum gipfel geladen ins neue
schloss von stuttgart noch die barock
kulisse ist gänzlich falsch für dieses
treffen denn es geht dort um neue
sachlichkeit und kahlschlag in der
energiepolitik auf die wir uns wohl
überall in deutschland einstellen müssen
eine konzertierte aktion um vom gas
runter zu kommen regierende werden da
diskutieren mit den energieversorgern
und die nutzer denen aus der industrie
und auch den aus dem handwerk die angst
haben dass ihnen das licht und die luft
ausgeht sandra susanka hat sie getroffen
er ist morgen beim gas gipfel in
stuttgart dabei rainer reichhold chef
der handwerkskammer in der region
stuttgart nicht nur er will endlich
wissen wie das gas im notfall verteilt
wird sagt uns was auf uns zukommt dass
wir uns darauf einstellen können wir die
dienstleister aber natürlich auch unsere
kunden somit ist natürlich die
bundesregierung gefordert die
rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen und im
land müsse schnellstmöglich umstellen
und bitte nicht so wie bei corona von
freitagnachmittag auf montag morgen
sondern perspektivisch ohne gas geht in
der gießerei johann chroma nicht täglich
schmelzen sie tonnenweise aluminium um
autoteile herzustellen die brauchen die
großen autobauer des landes dringend für
ihre produktion gas einsparen
funktioniert hier nicht denn weniger gas
bedeutet stillstand wir werden
wahrscheinlich in kurzarbeit gehen wir
wurden über personalreduzierungen
sprechen es werden aber alles maßnahmen
die nur kurzfristig helfen können
längerfristig hätten wir hier ganz
klaren existenz thema
nach 90 jahren unternehmensgeschichte
wollen sie nicht einfach tatenlos
zusehen so groß ist die verantwortung
und 350 arbeitsplätze hängen am standort
was also machen ein alternativer
brennstoff wäre vorhanden flüssigkeit
auch einen allen getankt haben sie schon
weitere sollen folgen aber die umrüstung
dauert und kostet viel geld baden
württemberg hat eine energieintensive
industrie deshalb treibt die
landesregierung mit blick auf die
gaslieferungen große sorgen um schon
jetzt wird im öffentlichen bereich
gespart mitarbeiter teilen sich
arbeitszimmer um energiekosten zu
reduzieren statt fahrstuhl soll die
treppe genommen werden und in den
toiletten gibt es nur noch kaltes wasser
jedes grad was man jetzt einspart dient
ja dazu auch real geld einzusparen
sicher wird man da noch
unterstützungsprogramme auch vom bund
brauchen aber wir wollen jetzt unseren
beitrag leisten wir wollen nicht warten
ob im kreml irgendwie der gashebel hoch
oder runter gestellt wird sondern wir
wollen jetzt handeln und uns
unabhängiger machen auch ein energiespar
büchler wurde neu aufgelegt um die
menschen im ländle auf
einsparmöglichkeiten im täglichen leben
hinzuweisen ich halte es für sehr
sinnvoll des bundesländer sich
vorbereiten und auch maßnahmen ergreifen
das bräuchten wir im übrigen auch
dringend in bayern aber auch in anderen
bundesländern wenn es darum geht dass
man eine gas versorgung sicherstellt
dass man möglichst mögliche
verteilungsprobleme die auftreten können
gerade im süden vermeidet und darum muss
es jetzt her gehen dass man auf einem
solchen gipfel das bespricht in
ludwigsburg ist man schon weiter für die
550.000 menschen des landkreises füllt
man zurzeit lager darin alles wichtige
um im bedarfsfall schnell wärme hallen
einzurichten betrieben von
hackschnitzelanlagen unabhängig vom gas
bis zu 5000 betten könnten sie
aufstellen kurz vor dem gas-gipfel hofft
man hier das der schlimmste fall nicht
eintritt und
jetzt kommst du hanna mit weiteren
nachricht vom sport ja und mit einem
strahlenden sieger der däne jonas
winkler hat die 109 tour de france
gewonnen für den 25 jährigen ist es der
erste gesamtsieg beim schwersten
radrennen der welt in der ball kam im
volk ins ziel auf den champs élysées in
paris auf der letzten etappe wird das
gelbe trikot traditionell nicht mehr
angegriffen
zur leichtathletik-wm in eugene bei der
die bisherige bilanz des deutschen teams
ziemlich ernüchternd war doch nun die
erste quartal und das am vorletzten
wettkampftag die 4 x 100 meter staffel
der frauen sprintete zu bronze gold ging
an die us amerikanerinnen silber an die
staffel jamaikas
in der formel 1 hat weltmeister
verstappen den großen preis von
frankreich gewonnen der red bull fahrer
profitierte von einem fahrfehler von
schale claire im ferrari führung liegend
war verstarb als ärgster konkurrent
ausgeschieden siebte saisonsieg also für
verstappen der seinen vorsprung in der
gesamtwertung weiter ausbauen konnte
wir stehen im halbfinale bei der
fußball-em und das weil die deutsche
nationalelf der frauen eine irre
entwicklung gemacht hat die wohl
prominenteste deutsche nationalspielerin
ist sie kapitänin alexandra popp sie hat
während der em in jedem spiel ihrer
mannschaft ein tor gemacht drei der vier
tore mit dem kopf
martin wolf unser fußballreporter aber
sagt dass die 31 jährige nicht nur
deshalb bewundert werde sondern wegen
ihrer leidensfähigkeit auch darüber hat
er mit ihr gesprochen
alexandra popps jubel läufer haben etwas
besonderes keiner reißt die anderen
derart mit ausnahmslos alle freuen sich
mit ihr selbst jene die sie auf die
bankvertreter wer einmal miterlebt hat
mit welch leidenschaftlichem einsatz um
jeden ball kämpft der kann kaum glauben
dass sie schon mal ans aufhören dachte
bei näherer betrachtung solcher bilder
wird der zusammenhang aber klar diese
frau hat sich immer wieder schwer
verletzt dass sie jetzt in england
erstmals eine em bestreiten kann grenzt
nach knorpelschaden im knie vor einem
jahr schon fast an ein wunder
ja meine gedanken waren schon so weit
dass ich eigentlich so weit war zu sagen
okay höre ich jetzt auch mit fußball und
war war nicht so einfach immer wieder
solche szenen
knie verdreht die bank entsetzt schlimme
schmerzen üble verletzungen zwei games
hat sie deshalb verpasst und sich dann
immer wieder herangekämpft nur selten in
der idyllischen rahmen wie hier bei der
reha im see alexandra popp gab alles für
ihre erste em teilnahme
ich wollte diesen kampf einfach annehmen
wenn ich ihm an ende verloren hätte wenn
das knie jetzt nicht so mitgemacht hätte
dann hätte ich mir aber wegen nicht
vorwerfen können ich hätte es nicht
versucht probier gibt einfach immer
alles geht immer vorneweg
ist ein leadertyp als pop deutschland
2010 22 weltmeistertitel schoss dürfte
sie kaum geahnt haben dass noch ein
olympiasieg sowie zahllose titel mit dem
vfl wolfsburg auf sie warteten zweimal
champions league siebenmal deutscher
meister und einmal pokalsieger
ganz nebenbei ausbildung zur
tierpflegerin der angebotene bürojob auf
der vfl geschäftsstelle wäre ihr ein
gräuel gewesen so viel lief gut in ihrem
leben doch pops em-fluch drohte wieder
zuzuschlagen als sie sich im
vorbereitungscamp positiv getestet auf
ihrem zimmer fit halten musste je länger
die tage vor allem auch ging
bin ich auch umso nervöser geworden ob
ich's dann auch wirklich schaffe dann
auch zur em wieder voll fit zu sein und
wie sie es geschafft hat ihre trainerin
konnte es kaum glauben als die
rekonvaleszenten nach späte einwechslung
gleich in ihrem ersten em spiel gegen
dänemark traf in typischer pop mania zum
4 0 mit dem kopf so wie auch beim 2 0
gegen spanien um den 13 uhr gegen
finnland nur zum 2 0 siegtreffer gegen
österreich verwendete sie mal ihren fuß
erfolgserlebnisse die sie zuversichtlich
stimmen vor dem halbfinale am mittwoch
gegen starke französinnen defensiv
glaube ich kann man sie mit gutem
umschaltspiel knacken dadurch dass sie
sehr offensiv einfach spielen gerade
auch mit ihren außenverteidigerinnen
sehe ich da glaube ich gute chancen dass
wir da auch in unserem schnellen
umschaltspiel nach vorne das heft in die
hand nehmen können einfach ein richtig
positiver typ diese alexandra popp
na dann viel glück für mittwoch das zdf
überträgt das spiel und zum sonntag
journal gehört immer unser ausblick in
die kommende woche heute von simon
hrubesch
[Musik]
am dienstag werden die energieminister
der eu zu einem ausserordentlichen
treffen in brüssel zusammenkommen grund
dafür ist die unsicherheit bei den
russischen gaslieferungen die minister
beraten wie die eu länder bei ihren
vorbereitungen auf den winter einen
solidarischen gemeinsamen weg gehen
können
die us notenbank federal reserve fed
wird am mittwoch die künftige
zinspolitik der usa bekannt geben um der
inflation zu begegnen wird mit einer
weiteren deutlichen anhebung des
leitzinses gerechnet für die entwicklung
der märkte ist entscheidend wie hoch die
anhebung ausfallen wird und wie die
künftige zinspolitik der fed aussehen
soll
außenministerin annalena baerbock wird
von donnerstag bis samstag auf
staatsbesuch in griechenland und der
türkei seien geplant sind gespräche über
die ukraine und die integration von
geflüchteten aber auch mit
zivilgesellschaftlichen akteuren will
sich berbalk treffen
in fast allen bundesländern sind bereits
schulferien auch in bayern heißt es dann
ab freitagnachmittag ferienzeit mit
beginn der bayerischen sommerferien wird
mit weiteren engpässen im flugverkehr
gerechnet dagegen bleibt der urlaub in
deutschland bei vielen reisenden
weiterhin hoch im kurs
steht noch der blick auf die
wetteraussichten morgen ziehen von der
nordsee schauer und teils kräftige
gewitter herein sonst bleibt es bei 25
bis 36 grad freundlich mit viel sonne in
den nächsten tagen wird es mit 17 bis 31
grad wie der kühler dabei bleibt es
meist trocken nur am dienstag müssen wir
noch häufiger mit schauern rechnen
so was jetzt kommt das können wir echt
empfehlen allein schon wegen der
fantastischen bilder von der seebühne
bregenz am bodensee zeigt das zdf madame
butterfly die oper von giacomo puccini
wir sind morgen wieder für sie da
christian sievers hier und hanna
zimmermann dort vielen dank guten start
in die woche
[Musik]